walter die visumspflicht mit 0 mit 0 mit
0 essen ich bin gleich oder tod ich bin
ins entweder tot
hallo willkommen zu einer neuen folge
hero 2 einer ganz besonderen
generationenfolge denn der könig dankt
ab und es muss ein neuer gewählt werden
deswegen haben auch die ganze stadt blau
versammelt mit samba dann auch schon
unsere ganze stadt leute und ich bin
immer noch in malta die wsv nicht mit
000 essen ich bin gleich wieder tot ich
bin ins entweder tot
wir können dich auch nicht wiederbeleben
das zweite königs volk in der ich sterbe
die konstanzer nein nein nein
jedoch finde einfach ein schwein oder so
ersten zwar schafe geben kann es nun
überhaupt aus dem haus war ein krieg ich
hab's gerettet stören
ich hab rolle kann ich wissen also wir
haben jetzt einen plan vor allem die
sänger den aus online warnten kannst du
probieren wir wollten einen geheimen
wahl abhalten denn kommt meine königs
regentschaft ist vorbei
das heißt ein neuer könig der wesentlich
mehr stärke und power zeigen muss als
ich muss gewählt werden
und wir haben uns schon gedanken gemacht
wie und rocken fans können nicht mehr zu
stadt sie haben sich beide für stadt
pink entschieden
ja und da nur einer stadt angehören kann
sind sie leider raus bin tot
jetzt liegt bei 290 120 wirklich über
290 120
das ist so ja wo das schiff liegt jetzt
so die kommt darauf die bank sal
du bist der friedenstraße bürger bei der
friedensstadt ja dass ich an hunger
sterben in diesem projekt und das zweite
mal dass ich in der königswall stärkt
und das zweite mal in folge
wer kann der kann der angreifer dabei
von euch ja aber in dieser folge wollten
war ja auch wählen wenn neuen könig
wählen
ja und können aber erst mal kurz mal
einen stadt roth vorbeischauen ich bin
halt auf entwickeln
ich kann ja später ein grabstein holt
niemand
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe ich
weiß gar nicht oder ist sie schwanger
ist oder katja dieckow original passte
gesagt aber das war ja so ungefähr oder
jedes mal respekt 100 kilometer laufen
wegen dem grabstein des jahres top
prioritäten jacke dos wobei ich könnte
mir ja ein portal zur friedensstadt
setzen
aber das schaffe ich nicht in fünf
minuten deswegen erst in der nächsten
folge womit hätte die portale mit die
man mir diese kann diese portaltüren
halt einfach ich gehe da mal den titel
screen ich glaube damit endet meine
wichtigste warte wen willst du sagt
bitte wenn du willst also ich sag noch
hier meiner folge wenig will und wer
dann könig wird das könnte ja dann in
den anderen folgen erfahren dann meine
zuschauer diese hero folge gegen fünf
minuten
dafür möchte ich ihnen ja ich will also
wenn ich wählen dürfte dann würde ich
sie wählen
aber ich bin ich der mich ja nicht mal
auf so und wie dieses problem gelöst
wird meine lieben zuschauer das erfahrt
ihr auf den anderen kanälen das war fest
ich fand es witzig kinos wo ist denn da
bleibe ich jetzt so klappt hat keine
ahnung dass das schlecht ich fand stark
von dir
ich finde es stark gemacht das ist nicht
also mgm jetzt lena klatschen
ich bin halt in der stadt hier ist
keiner ich bin jetzt auch ein stadt roth
kämpfen ich bin auch ein statt rot ich
hab keine ahnung
der aber wir müssen das problem des
wählens lösen das ding ist ich darf
nicht noch einmal gewählt werden
und es stellt sich niemand zur wahl man
darf kein zweites mal gewählt werden
hier nicht ineinander also deswegen
danach definiert werden das heißt es
muss ein anderer könig gefunden werden
eigentlich ungünstig war mir das
persönlich egal gewesen ob ich dann noch
mal gewählt werde aber nun gut und das
heißt wir haben uns für was ganz
spezielles entschieden ja der film nicht
mehr verschwendete zeit hier
dort musste grube wo bist du statt rot
ja ich bin jetzt anstieg ist schiff
vorbei und auf simon baumann 1 1
ich finde doch jetzt nicht mein flugzeug
starten wollte ich weiß wo ich bin dein
flugzeug staat legal team von minus
3.000 schenken wirklich hab mir doch ein
ja fast kaputt ist das keine deswegen
ich bin tot ist tot
ja jungs wir haben eigentlich eine
lösung gefunden
sommer ich bin hinter dir
das zeigt uns den neuen könig denn
hingestellt hingestellt ich weiß nicht
erwischt er habe ich einfach ein käse
verlieren erzählte einen dreck dass
unser neuer könig und wenn mir der name
eingefallen ist fast komplett
ja ich kann mir nicht unbedingt
eingespielt ist drauf ich nenne ihn um
ok unglück zwar folgen der name tobago
also etwas tristen schreibt mir dass die
uns jetzt nicht angreifen sollen wenn
ihr königswall ist unser könig bei mal
ein ton aus enstone und stell ihn
irgendwo in die stadt mal nicht klappt
ist herbert alle
er ist okay gar kein problem cooler typ
ich meine vielleicht sportliche der
nächsten folge habt ihr ohne irgend
etwas zu essen und mit vollem hunger des
supertankers wenn das einer kann dann du
dann kann ich genau wende das ist das
krieg ich noch hinten hattrick ach so
wollten wir das ist ja ein supergeiles
material
habt ihr noch mehr sagt diese vorbehalte
manchmal aus holz ein könig würdig ich
hab nen halben stack sand ist das ein
könig würde ich ja klar
wie war es mit entsteint ich habe jetzt
schon sand angefangen ich bin nun mal
ein paar zähne dass er sich nicht bewegt
der könig ist zwar frei er darf sich
aber nicht bewegen wohlgemerkt
ihr habt richtig gehört das ist keine
vaterschaft folge da keiner könig sein
will und ich ein ast ranzel könig sein
und ich nicht kann ist es dann so dass
wir einfach das goldene schoko wählen
ja das ist jetzt das wird wirklich die
stadt zu neuem glanz und neuer browser
fällt jedoch wie genau vermessen n jungs
liegen und damit den er könig chocobo
lucio co er wolle mir das europabüro in
oberbauer erste kuba wo der erste muster
dahinter druck da wo schon ein eher
rover dass fast jeder jeder muss dem
könig tribut zollen und ihn verehren als
wäre ein junger gott in gold fließen
lässt das ist jedem rad geht ist ein
dienst mit artigen knicks erforderlich
du musst dich hinhocken wie ein
schulmädchen knick den sieg beenden
kassenstand von verkäufen ich zeige euch
jetzt ein tutorial wie das geht ist zum
beispiel ein vorbei ständig hin und dann
einfach weiter das muss man machen wenn
man das nicht macht wird man gewarnt
in dem haus und ich denke ihr könnt auch
gerne als zuschauerin war meine aus
wurst war ja komm doch her
neben dem turm neben deiner montalvo
kuba oder da sitzt der besitzt selbst
selbstverständlich auch eine partei
unterstützen können und zwar ist es die
wob partei zu kuba direkt in meine liebe
jubilar kann ich das noch eins tiefer
erste
dann aber schon wieder illegal mit das
ist die kühne gesamte königin
das ist immer emanzipation ist
anatomisch sei ist wenn wir von einer
königin ein haus bauen gleichen knicks
machen würde ich sagen man muss einfach
die wand davor so ein bisschen anders
aber sein penis rausholen ich einen
kleinen wink mit dem penis probierens
und schlenkers und helikopter und alles
gut
nicht alle unsere königin
das läuft jetzt endlich anordnung so ist
es recht finde ich schön finde ich schön
und ich mache mir jetzt einmal portal
zufrieden staaten einmal portal ist ein
großer krieg das haben was zu stadt pink
ach ja genau wir wollten mich auch noch
alles abreißen was hier irgendwie von
revieren alte mann wenn stars ja niemals
zur stadt gehören und es ist nicht so
dass man einfach so zwischendurch
zwischen kann der könig könnte zwar
sagen ja irgendwann wirklich einfach
wieder aber wartet fragen wir doch mal
königin tobago der erste schöne kindheit
die er ist nicht der erste verbrennt
gehen die erste mal um den knick
vergessen hatte den zaun wenigstens
anständig vor ihr weg gesammelt ja
natürlich so gehalten hat auch anmerken
dass man ihn vergessen natürlich auch
gerne unsere königin im tribut in den
kommentaren sollen kann gedichte reden
wunderschöne geschichten und zeichnungen
die freut sich bestimmt die königin
liest immer mit in den kommentaren und
alt geht es immer mit ihr könnt ihr euch
verlassen
es wird auch königs konfis geben dann
selbstverständlich wieder so wie damals
auch schon wurde an unsere königin dabei
sein wird hat werden wir natürlich da
aus textauszüge in die kommentare posten
also selbstständig denn wenn die könige
hat aus unserer hashtag und die
selbstständig schreiben sollte dann das
ist unsere partei so ist es eigentlich
er hilft mir mal einer beim hausbau hier
welches haus musste welcher ist kommt
die hälfte von reben haben ist einfach
anzünden
es geht schnell das brauchen wir doch
eben für alles was wir aus stimmt stimmt
denn eigentlich war für gratis marvel
ist auch so so also ich königin chocobo
die erste ich gehe jetzt erstmal noch
heißt jedoch wahrlich als turbo für
tobacco königin chocobo die erstmals
erstmal nix
würden sie mir erlauben dass ich meinen
grundstück von kef zu hier verlagern da
verlagern darf wenigen klubs hat ja
gesagt warte ich höre ja das waren ja
ich glaub mir besitzt einfach immer so
eine stimme machen wenn wir mit ihr
reden
sie erlaubt einfach das was wir wollen
und wenn wir das nicht wollen dann
erlaubt sie es auch nicht sie ist
einfach immer unsere meinung und wenn
wir halt las in der stadt vorantreiben
wollen erstmal gespannt sollen englich
langkow im prettiner menschen
kev frau kümmert sich um nahrung bitte
diesen monat lang ich nicht mehr ich
meine kongress okay aber nicht königin
chocobo knicks sollte sich diesen monat
und nahrung kümmern
du bist schon letzte was ein land ist
das eigentlich noch da ja ok aber ich
finde das ja ja ich wollte ich überlege
mir gerade wie ich jemals wieder
zurückkommen soll wenn ich jedes mal mit
hunger
einmal sogar erst mal mache ich halt für
zufrieden statt das heißt wir können
jederzeit jetzt abholen das dauert fünf
minuten dann bist du nicht direkter und
zweitens wird hat sich wie sofort in den
futter farben zu machen und zwar im farm
ich mir gerade ein schwein eschborner
zusammen den ich mit einer gezielten
lover falle zu stecken das weg farben
umfunktionieren
und dann haben wir das problem ist am
main gab es ja anscheinend auf dem
portal aber wenn du einfach spaß mit vor
dem hunger und am verrecken bis dann
suchst du kein portal sondern essen und
da war aber nichts ist die stadt pink
das bild böhm an der stadtrodaer ja ja
ich habe nur wegen mir das hab ich ihn
weg damals
man hat sich aber auch einmal entdeckt
nach mir das gesagt ja okay was genau
wie genau das jetzt der plan gegen die
anderen städte königin chocobo die erste
knicks auf krieg frieden einfach hunger
wir brauchen plant wollen wir wollen wir
so bei vier oder mehr
also es ist ein junge der könig ist
kriegt er doch nicht doch quatsch
nachdem das auch schon wieder auf simon
spielkarten ja genug hat gesagt das geld
königswall ist deswegen glaube ich noch
verschont
ich muss doch nur checken ob das hier
wirklich allein und wir sind zu dritt
und ich habe mir beim letzten mal auch
besiegt also so geht es sicherlich immer
in der angst vor mir das ist heftig ich
hätte netbsd okay ich bin jetzt hier in
der nähe
ich fliege noch mal kurz zum podium
einfach nur um zu schauen ob das schon
irgendwas ist wenn ja dann setze ich mir
eine portal tür natürlich die codemeter
ich baue gerade das haus ab 8 sondern es
auch ja ich brauche es auch in den
nächsten folgen weiter weil sich jemand
anders macht danke wie sehe ich ja nix
das motiv dürfte ganz ehrlich gegenden
gesprochen wird das hat gerade die
königin gesagt ich hab's gehörten leute
ohne witz ihre bildung hier ist nichts
gebaut die können hier nicht wohnen
die sind solche die koordinaten nennen
ja mama bitte war ich bin ja bei diesen
preisen kann ich machen weil ich war
doch schon mal moment blo blo blo blo
blo blo blo ein pilz japaner machen
wer will und zwar bei auf jeden fall
eines essens mit 103.000 13.000 213.000
wie 13.000 der 30 mehrere pilz biome
dass die erste kurve das ist auch in der
stadt
aber das ist dass das ist statt pink ich
bin hier bei 32 objektiv also 31 simon
hatte auch irgendwie einen spiegel dahin
gemacht deswegen kann es auch glaube ich
sein das ist einfach ein komplett
anderes pilz biomasse also 13.000 was
dann
13 also da ist aus 200 und dann 4300 das
ist eine insel relativ displays
immanente
ich habe es gerade die kleinen kreis weg
da die taliban auch mein zoll groß
siehst du mal was für eine begeisterten
situation nicht aktuell bin als das
heißt ich muss ja richtig lange fliegen
das schaffe ich in der folge auf keinen
fall darüber zu gehen
und ja das heißt diese folge nicht
vollwertig fliegen wir haben jetzt eine
königin
ich finde dieses eigentlich haben wir
überhaupt männlichen begleiter für die
königin damit wir königlichen nachwuchs
in empfang nehmen kann das übernehmen
was luca du findest luca deine aufgabe
jetzt ein kind zu zeugen
da muss ein game show kobr auskommen ich
reite sie lauern noch mehr rüstung
konnte sie gerade
okay vielleicht sollte dann in genau
einem monat anstatt den neun monaten
dann kind kommen müsste eigentlich wenn
ich das nächste welle in skype konfus
und in den youtube kommentaren den knick
und reiben und sich in italien haben wir
machen keine knicke man einig war so ich
hab das ein jugendlich gestorben
deswegen ich habe das nie ich wollte
dass ich für das gut ok also ich kann
ich leider nicht wiederbeleben das habe
ich so folge nicht dass das das passt
das machen wir nachher aus wie wir wie
wir die rettung des des desktops
veranstalten ich weiß gar nicht wie es
ausschaut die folge müsst ihr auch
gleich zu ende sein nimmt einer von euch
noch weiter heute auf ja ich muss nach
bisschen ich auf weiß nicht ob das was
bringt heute abend oder heute nacht auf
heute abend der summe geschoss videos
hatte ich nicht vor
eine folge wurde gar noch gehen oder 2
ich bedanke mich würde ja nicht schwer
beliebt dann darf ich zwölf stunden auf
dem server er deswegen ja stellt wieder
einmal wissen dass jetzt in der folge
spricht danach nein nein nur weil du
immer nur [ __ ] bumsen blase in seinen
videos willst du gar ist das nicht das
bin ich mal was seriöses betrieb ist das
gar nicht ernst das projekt g simon
maier oder was sagt unsere königin
ok ja gut meine damen herren um die
folge kommt zusammen zu fassen wir haben
nun eine königin
dies hilft und ich bin der karte das
heißt mehr oder weniger muss sich
beistand leisten bei jochen nicht erst
wenn du den königlichen sammlung zu
liest man schwarz-weiß luca beischlaf
nein auch bei königs konfis damit ich so
für die königin eventuell auch sprechen
kann
machen sie wenn die anderen die sprache
kündigen nicht verstehen die jetzt
verstehen der vienna
aber ich erzähle gelungene königshaus
abgerissen
naja wenn ich tag ich bin fast bei stadt
pink so wie ich das sehe also bin ich
bei 6.000 4000 könntet ihr mann küsste
mich mit ja auch steine mitgenommen ist
einmalig will auch eine als könnte jetzt
sagen weil ich neugierig bietet fliege
ich glaube du hast du gerade auf
gesammelten kräfte dann könntet ihr spaß
ich habe diesen diesen kölner fortune
habe ich der macht wir müssen jetzt
verhält und überziehen war massiv ich
habe auch immer minuten
ich habe noch drei minuten aber nicht
aufgenommen werden was alle view war der
fliegt übels langsamer das gebiet nicht
mehr ändern warum gesten statt pinke
portal das portal dass weder ich
hingehen können weiß jemand die aufnahme
zeiten von denen ich habe die noch nie
spielen gesehen immer nur unter
bestimmten tageszeit man aufnehmer nur
montags und mittwochs irgendwie zwischen
20 jahren und genau und das ist die
schwäche ist allein deswegen will ich
keine zweite folge auf nämlich morgen
abend nämlich online falls das portal in
der folge noch hinkriegt
ob sie als im vorjahr sagt du machst
jetzt noch eine folge der mars portal
einer will sich morgen abend auf und
dann töte ich sie einfach alleine will
ich nicht eine folge will ich machen
weil morgen uni und so bin ich müde und
läuft bei dirk f ja ich will ja machen
wir das denn wenn luca sich einfach mit
cap bespricht und ich beschreibe ich
spreche nicht mit sondern weil ich habe
eigentlich gutes skript innenstadt ping
sobald ich den stadtring bin
das haben die 100 prozent
du hast gar nichts nee das ist dass es
das hat mir hat mir versprochen wenn
diese versprechen darauf dass erdöl ich
finde wir sind ein gutes
abrissunternehmen ja ja also vor allem
auch wie wir vorgehen erst mal unten die
ganzen schnellsten weg so daß es in der
luft schwebt abgesehen
statistisch gesehen ist allererste sahne
was wir hier also ich eigentlich sagen
wir sollten so ein schwarzes brett in
der friedensstadt machen wo ihr exklusiv
für die anderen städte ihre dienste
anbieten könnte sagt ja wollte keinen
ausweg abriss industries meldet euch wir
machen alles klein genau wieso ziehen
kisten und sowas oha das sehr heftig
wenn man sowas anbieten würde dann
werden wir wanderhure okay ihr müsst auf
den timer schaumainkai maßen wird falls
wir haben noch eine halbe minute jetzt
ist meine ganz einfach fertig wir haben
im haushalt abgerissen ich weiß es in
meiner nächsten folge fertig habe ich
weiß auch noch ein bisschen dann bin ich
immer aufnahme ist jetzt auf fast schon
wieder aufnimmst darauf dass sich die
erde angreifen kann
ja da mache ich das auch morgen abend
okay wenn man das ding ist wenn ich ja
und bin ich leute noch eine variante
wartet dann nehme ich auch morgen abend
auf dann treffen uns einfach so wieder
okay der trainer konnte aber ich muss
mir noch nie so suchen weil im wasser
kann ich empfehlen den schoko nicht
stehen bis zum nächsten schuss